alors vanessa paradis vous êtes devenue
une mère très très attentive est
ordonnée maintenant avant on fait les
valises quand vous partez en quand vous
partez en vacances c'était vachement
sérieuse donc qui ont offert une
interview très sérieuses et c'est
l'interview expliqué à ma fille en la
bouche
m
votre fille vous demande maintenant
pourquoi on met en corner
ce qui en soi est un début un milieu et
une fin
et puis il faut bien que ça s'arrête au
bout d'un moment on devient complètement
un ramassis à la cuillère mais après il
ya autre chose je dirais ça sert à quoi
de travailler puisqu'il suffit d'aller à
la machine pour prendre de l'argent
baa à occuper ses journées et a mangé
mon père et 10 et le texte si la liberté
l'argent mais j'aime bien cette
expression pour ça que si c'est ça c'est
vrai que rendre la famille en ce moment
c'est quoi ce que vous mettez dans vos
cigarettes avec papa
à masi et n'ont jamais quittée pour
l'instant annoncée du tabac donc non
mais de toute façon j'ai lui expliquerai
je souhaitais puisse passer les
frontières tranquille baby kg aussi aux
états unis moi pourquoi papa il a fait
un baiser sur la bouche à la baby sitter
150 balles de leurs on peut quand même
pas un bisou maman pourquoi on tombe sur
moi la radio en ce moment parce que
parce que les juristes un peu trop mes
chansons lady maman qu'est la question
qui n'a pas de réponse c'est sur les
gosses c'est pourquoi pourquoi je t'aime
pas de réponse c'est comme ça qu'on voit
là bas
non